[Música]
quizás no lo crean Pero estas imágenes
fueron filmadas hace poco en Siria el
hombre que se ve en ellas es gustav un
youtuber danés con cerca de 300.000
suscriptores
al igual que él influenciadores
occidentales ahora viajan a Siria con un
mensaje en común el país no es el que
ustedes creen es muy acogedor
Pero estos vídeos que reciben millones
de vistas se hacen con el aval del
régimen sirio Su contenido es
principalmente a político comida
[Música]
piscinas
o lugares arqueológicos
[Música]
todos estos vídeos fueron filmados en
zonas controladas por el régimen de
bachata para nuestro observador director
de una ong de Derechos Humanos en Siria
este enfoque de los youtubers se ajusta
a la propaganda del régimen sirio
nadie dice que esos videos filmados en
bares o en restaurantes sean falsos o
inventados
Pero la idea global es que esos vídeos
no son más que fragmentos parciales
puedo asegurar que esas imágenes solo
muestran una pequeña parte de la
realidad en Siria
estamos hablando de un país casi
destruido donde más del 90% de la
población vive bajo el umbral de la
pobreza
claro la vida sigue pero presentar un
lugar así como el estándar de las
condiciones de vida en Siria ese es el
problema
es imposible creer que los turistas y
los youtubers que uno ve en Siria
vinieron sin el consen previo del
gobierno sirio
contactado por nuestra redacción el
youtuber danés gustavsted nos contestó
lo siguiente siempre hay críticas cuando
se visitan estos países todo lo que
produce durante mi visita Siria está
financiado por mis propios medios soy
solo un joven que ama viajar para hablar
con la gente local no me interesa la
política por su parte otra youtuber la
polaca Eva shueck nos aseguró que nadie
la había invitado y que solamente había
publicado sus opiniones sin ninguna
obligación o censura sin embargo estos
influenciadores siempre están
acompañados Por guías que están
habilitados por el régimen en varias
imágenes observamos la presencia del
mismo hombre logramos identificar a este
guía su nombre es rami nahuaya y resulta
ser el cuñado del viceministro sirio de
turismo cuando Romina aguaya acompañó al
youtuber británico Simon Wilson alepo
dio su versión sobre la batalla que
ocurrió en la ciudad [__] sea miren
Esto entonces todo este lugar fue
completamente destruido por misiles y
todo eso no es así es una guerra no se
puede saber realmente que lo destruyó se
utilizaron toda clase de armas los
militantes tenían toda clase de armas
estaban apoyados por Turquía pero lo que
ramiahuaya no dice es que el régimen
sirio y su Aliado ruso bombardearon
extensamente alepo en particular Durante
los últimos días de la batalla en 2016
en sus vídeos todos los youtubers van a
ciudades en ruinas pero se abstienen de
mencionar quién estuvo implicado en las
destrucciones y cuáles fueron las
consecuencias
faltan paredes hay Varillas de metal
torcidas por todas partes
no se lo pueden imaginar verdad los
horrores que el pueblo sirio padeció
Durante este conflicto
además de Romina Guaya existen otros
guías y agencias que acompañan a los
youtubers por su parte las autoridades
sirias no esconden su satisfacción el
viceministro de turismo afirmó en julio
de 2022 que los influenciadores que
comparten sus imágenes con una amplia
audiencia han representado una gran
promoción para Siria esto nos sorprende
a basán alamat para quien estos vídeos
fomentan la propaganda del régimen sirio
el régimen o el gobierno sirio es
responsable de muchas sino de la mayoría
de las infracciones de Derechos Humanos
en este país
estos vídeos al no presentar otras
versiones en particular las versiones de
las víctimas se pueden considerar como
una participación directa en las
campañas de desinformación en Siria
rami mi hermano sirio de otra madre
Muchas gracias por este tour
Gracias a ustedes por atraer la atención
sobre Siria por darle a las personas una
imagen auténtica de Siria pero el final
de las operaciones militares no
significa el final del conflicto en
Siria no significa que los derechos la
justicia y la responsabilidad se hayan
establecido y sobre todo no significa
que las personas hayan retomado su vida
normal antes de 2011
estos videos se dirigen a un público
occidental pero también son vistos en
Siria
en un país donde al menos 14.500
personas han padecido actos de tortura
desde 2011 Este vídeo impresionó a
muchos sirios
el régimen sirio es responsable de miles
incluso de decenas de miles de casos de
tortura Entonces cuando un youtuber
utiliza en su video términos como
tortura en un contexto totalmente
distinto para mí una intención de
ridiculizar y minimizar esto
le reitero este mensaje a los youtubers
y a cualquier persona que tenga
curiosidad por descubrir la realidad de
este país destruido Siria hagan énfasis
en la versión de las víctimas en la
violación de los Derechos Humanos
cometida no solo por el régimen sino por
todas las partes que han participado en
este conflicto
contactamos a todos estos youtubers solo
gustav Roster y Eva shueck nos
contestaron Por otra parte no obtuvimos
ninguna respuesta de parte del
Ministerio sirio del turismo
y así llegamos al final de los
observadores por esta semana si desean
ponerse en contacto con nuestro equipo y
hacer parte de la red de observadores
como siempre todos nuestros contactos
aparecen en sus pantallas hasta la
próxima semana